[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's pretty tough to make sense of our
world today
we've got the former deck athlete the
guy on the wheaties box
may very well become the first female
governor of california
we are told that we need to get race
entirely out of our politics but we're
told this by people who
view politics primarily as a matter of
race
we are told that we need to be very
scientific by people who deny
objective truth i don't know how to make
heads or tails i guess they've already
succeeded
one guy who who really i think is so
perceptive
about these sorts of things you may have
heard of him you may well not have heard
of him though
is vocal distance a great twitter follow
you can follow him at
local w-o-k-a-l underscore
distance you can probably spell that one
out
you can find him on youtube but more
importantly you can find him right here
today
local first of all thank you for coming
on
thank you for having me second of all
i'm trying to reconcile
the myriad contradictions that that are
being
foisted upon me by the dominant culture
and i'm not talking about some radicals
in the streets though i guess they're
part of it
i'm talking about by everything by the
corporations by the administrative
government
by entertainment by the whole kit and
caboodle
how am i to to make sense of this sort
of thing
well i i think to put it simply we are
living in the post-modern era
we have moved through modernism and we
are now living in post-modernism
okay and uh let's let's take a nice
little way to
think about this is um
well let's make two points about this
first off i don't think post-modernism
is good
i think we should get through it as
quickly as we possibly can and then i
think the second point is to make us a
little bit of an understanding of what
post-modernism is
and so i think a good place to start
with that is there was a post-modern
philosopher named jean baudrillard
and jean baudrillard said that we are
living in a
in a simulation in the world of
simulacra and simulation it's a
he wrote a book and i believe it was
1980 called simulacra in simulation it's
a very difficult read so
um it can it can be tough to get your
head around he said we're living in a
hyper reality where everything is
inauthentic
and i think here's a good way to get
your head around it
let's pretend that you and i are living
in ancient rome and you and i are
walking along the road and we find some
wild strawberries and we go and we pick
them
and we eat them those strawberries
are real now fast forward to the 1960s
and you and i are still alive because
we've discovered the fountain of youth
yeah it's like we're like dr fauci you
know the ages come and go but we seem to
remain yeah
yeah we we are we are immortal and we're
walking along and we go to the
supermarket and we buy strawberries now
those strawberries
are grown in a factory setting and only
the biggest
most beautiful juiciest ripest
strawberries get picked and given to us
and they're they only plant the nicest
strawberries the nicest seeds
so they're they're real strawberries
still but they're selectively grown
strawberries
they're the pinnacle of what a
strawberry could be yep
so then you and i sit around and think
and we have all of our knowledge that we
had from ancient rome
until 1916 we say hey let's make
a strawberry candy we're gonna distill
that flavor of the strawberry and we're
gonna
put it into a little candy so we make
the strawberry candy
fast forward to the 1970s you know you
and i think hey maybe we could sell more
of these candies if we make them a
little sweeter so we distill the flavor
and make it even more powerful than a
strawberry is
we make we make that ten times as
powerful as a strawberry and we add
sugar
well fast forward to the 1990s and the
jolly rancher company comes along and
says you know
using real strawberries and sugar is
expensive we're going to use
a synthetic strawberry flavor and high
fructose corn syrup
and they make the jolly rancher but then
the soft drink company comes along and
says we're going to make
a soda pop of the strawberry flavored
jolly rancher
and then 7-eleven comes along in
7-eleven or some other company comes
along and says we're going to make
a slurpee that is flavored like the soda
that is flavored like the jolly rancher
which is flavored like the candy which
is flavored like the original candy
which is flavored like the genetically
modified strawberry which is
flavored like the wild strawberry so
we're starting with the wild
strawberries and then we move
to the the the perfectly selectively
grown strawberry then we go to the candy
then we go to the jolly rancher
then we move to the soda pop then we
move to the slurpee and by the time we
get to the slurpee we're
dealing with something that is vaguely
like a strawberry that tastes maybe a
little like a strawberry but isn't
really anything like a strawberry so
my son could go along and he he picks up
the slurping he starts drinking
the strawberry slurping as he's walking
along the road he sees these funny kind
of
red shaped things in the background kind
of over there
and he goes and he picks one and he goes
this kind of looks like the little
logo on my my drink here and he takes it
and goes
it kind of maybe tastes vaguely like
this slurpee thing but it's not nearly
as good i'll drink the slurpee
that's an example of a of a simulacrum
of a thing that is
a copy of a copy of a copy of a copy of
a copy
and what baudrillard thought was that
everything is kind of like that we're
dealing with copies of copies of copies
of copies of copies of copies of things
now baudrillard pushes this idea and he
thinks that
for example we could talk about i don't
know women
back in rome there's women and they're
just walking around fast forward to the
1960s and there's women but we've
invented makeup
so fast forward to the 1970s and we've
invented mega band we've invented birth
control
and then fast forward to the 80s when we
have makeup and we have birth control
and we have breast implants yeah and
then you add to the go
forward to the 1990s and then you add
the photoshop
then you fast forward to instagram and
you have a woman who's wearing makeup
and has
uh a wig on and she's on birth control
and she has blessed implants and she's
got
uh 14 layers of makeup on and she's been
photoshopped and on top of that she has
a wonderful little filter on
and all of a sudden you're you're so far
away from what a regular person looks
like that it's
it's it's more real than real it's
it's a woman that nobody could ever
aspire to look like you could never have
the skin tone
of a filter that doesn't exist it's not
real
but it's pointed through to you and
baudrillard thinks we're stuck here
and he thinks we can't ever get back to
reality no i think i would like to say
that we can
i think i see where you're going with
this i was i was trying to figure out
how does the jolly rancher
relate to caitlyn jenner but you've just
explained how the jolly rancher relates
to caitlyn jenner that
caitlyn jenner is a hyper real woman
she's more woman
than a woman she he she he he is
now this appearance of this woman in
such an exaggerated
and caricatured way but
whereas i might think that this is a
very strange turn of events that bruce
jenner now
looks like this kind of exaggerated
woman what you're suggesting
perhaps is that we're living in this
hyper real world
so of course we're going to get a
caitlyn jenner yeah
i i would say i would say it it kind of
works like this the
the movement of the transgenderist
movement or the transgender movement
the gender ideological movement whatever
you want to call it
has basically latched on to the symbols
of femininity
the symbols of womanhood and have
abstracted those away from the women who
actually wore them
and have turned that into the thing that
is a woman
so they would say that being a woman is
a purely social role
it's entirely a socially constructed
thing kind of like the presidency or the
job of being a lawyer or being a mailman
so talking to them about a biological
woman
would be a little bit like trying to
talk about a biological male man
they would they would say no they would
say a woman isn't this
this biological entity a woman is a
social role
of of a person who follows particular
norms in a particular society
so they would say they've taken all the
things
of uh that women have have
added to their arsenal of of social
signification
they've taken all the things that women
have brought onto themselves makeup
wearing dresses using the color pink
having eyeliner
wearing heels and they've said that the
thing that constitutes the woman is all
the symbols
and the social role that they play it's
got nothing to do with the underlying
biological reality okay i'd like to mix
metaphors for a second
about men before i'd like so what you're
saying is in a sense we've put the cart
before the horse
and to be a little more precise here
we've confused the symbol
for the symbolized for the thing that
the symbol is referring to
yes okay yes beaudry art explicitly
states
that we are living in a world where the
only thing that does anything is the
symbols
yes the symbols are the whole world
that's it so
the underlying reality he says rots away
he says
you can't ever get to the reality
because the only thing that you're
operating on is the level of symbols
every time you look at something
when you when i look at you michael
knowles i i don't see
a man or a person i see the wedding ring
and that's a symbol
of being married and i see the jacket
that's a symbol of being at work
and i see the leftist tears and that
symbol of intelligence and i see the
michael knowles show and that's the
symbol of the show
the underlying person is is completely
removed
i can't get to that the only thing i
have access to is the symbols
yes right okay this makes sense i've
wrapped my head around this
i agree with your observation i would
say with beaudrier's observation but you
should take credit for it i take credit
for all sorts of ideas that i just read
in some books somewhere
now we agree that this is what's going
on okay fine
i want to know first how did we get here
and then second and more importantly how
do we get out of it
okay so there's a couple of things that
have that have happened um
in 1993 there was a book written by a
man named stanley gren's called a primer
on post-modernism
and he argues in that book that we have
moved into the post-modern epoch or the
post-modern age
he says it's as significant to shift as
moving from say the middle ages to the
enlightenment
okay he thinks we've now moved from the
enlightenment into the post-modern age
and so baudrillard in 1980 is writing
about this
now you have to think he's writing about
this in 1980 and in the 80s
when how you know when we have landline
phones and network tv
he thinks you are awash in us in symbols
and information to the point where you
can't see the real world
you'd have to wonder what do you think
looking around now yeah
right he'd look around now be like what
what right so
the way that the postmodern person views
the world
is to say that the thing that we have
access to is the signs and the symbols
right that's what we're walking around
in that everything is socially
constructed including your methods of
knowing
yeah right science is is a particular to
them
it is a way of knowing right that's
culturally validated
right and that there could be other
culturally adequate ways of knowing and
all that you have is ways
of knowing and constructing ideas and
constructing knowledge right
so they would say that it's that that
what we call
for example science is is a sort of
here's a technical term which i'll
unpack legitimation by purology
okay and what that would mean is that
things are true because there's enough
social momentum in society for the
society to consider those things to be
true
but if pardon my interruption so if but
let's say that there's enough
momentum in society for society to
consider something to be true
last time i checked truth is not based
on consensus right i mean
truth is based on objective reality
correct
so they have a different conception of
truth and a good way to get at that if
you want to really
undercut them here's a nice way to think
about it
it was i believe in the in the 80s or
90s there was a building built at the at
on on the campus of ohio state
university called the winter sex
wexner center for the performing arts
and it was a postmodern building
and so it runs at different angles to
itself so it's not a clean grid
um you can see bits of the foundation
and bits of the infrastructure and the
scaffolding poking out at various parts
that have doors that lead to nowhere and
the idea was
that all of the architectural norms and
patterns and things that we use to
understand architecture are random
yeah and arbitrary so why can't we just
break all those
and the nice way to get it at how to
undercut kind of that's that's their
view right that
if it's all arbitrary and socially
constructed we can do that and so the
question that you might want to ask
those people is
okay so you made all the the lines and
the windows
and the doors you put them in arbitrary
places used arbitrary shapes and
arbitrary directions okay did you do
that with the foundation
and the answer is going to be no yeah
because much like your ideas about the
world
the foundation is the place where the
building connects to the world
and if the place where you connect to
the world isn't set on a good foundation
the whole thing's going to collapse
right so that's kind of where we're at
right now is that
we are beginning we are in a postmodern
world
where we're getting where people are
getting away from the reality
where they're they're in isolated
bubbles of information
where where the social
pressure is dictating the belief set
nothing to go on
with the real world you know that's the
situation we're living in
this reminds me i i once asked speaking
of the grievance studies sorts of uh
experiments that
we were talking about a bit earlier uh
peter boghossian who is
one of the people behind that once
explained to me that intersectionality
is uh posits that the only thing that i
can know
with certainty is my own suffering
and i thought this was an interesting
key into intersectionality and it i i
see there okay you need this at some
connection
to the world you need some connection to
reality here and so for these
woke people in the grievance studies it
can it can be my resentment or my
suffering or my whatever but there there
has to be some link okay
so then right there's some link here
you're right they won't they won't mess
with the foundation of the building
but they're they're destroying
everything else people saw this coming
in the 1980s
very few people but at least this one
guy saw it coming in the 1980s
it had been building for a while before
that but how did you even get to that
point in the 80s how did you even get to
the point where people could see this
happening
well i i think there's a few things that
were going on i think
beaujolais was very pessimistic about
this and as he moves on through his
career he actually uh
he wrote a book in 1991 called the gulf
war did not take place
and his his whole thing is he thinks
look the thing that you saw on tv didn't
happen something happened but we don't
know what it is
right he thinks that it was a it was a
show that was put on
right he says the united states wants to
play the role of the good guy
and though they're casting saddam
hussein in the role of the bad guy
and here we go we're going to have a
fake war that's that's kind of how
vaudevillard sees it
now the thing with baudrillard that we
want to avoid at all costs is
beaudrillart accepts the premise that
reality is gone
that we can't get to it and what we
would want to do is we want to look at
beaujolais and say okay beaudrier you've
made some interesting observations about
how social abstractions can get away
from reality but
that doesn't mean the reality is gone
it's still here
not even beaujard's gonna step in front
of a bus right right
so if you if you rewind a little bit
there's some philosophy that's going on
in the
in the 60s 70s and 80s that really kind
of pushes this and it comes from a
couple of guys
uh jacques darda and michelle foucault
and
i can't explain those guys in just a few
minutes but
suffice to say that how do i put this
as complicated as their ideas were
what was taken out from their ideas and
from their philosophy
what was abstracted out was the idea
that there is no central or correct
perspective that there is no inherent
fixed and stable meaning in language
and there is no stable correct
proper appropriate categories all those
things are arbitrary
you know i i love the distinction you've
made here because
you say you can't sum up these radical
theorists like foucault
or derrida in three minutes frankly i
don't think we could sum them up in
three years or 30 years and
frankly i don't even know if they could
sum themselves up in certain things that
they said
but but regardless who cares i i frankly
i don't even care that i mean i'm
interested as an intellectual matter
what foucault or derrida thought but
what i care more about
is the effect that they had what was
taken out of their philosophy
there's a line that people love to quote
from derrida which is
uh variously translated as there is
nothing outside of the text or there
but then derrida's defenders come in and
they say no actually he said
there is no outer text and then they're
trying to find all these semantic
distinctions
well pardon my uh bluntness
who cares if the effect of it is that
people interpret the man to mean there's
nothing outside the text
that really everything is just
constructed everything is
is a matter of language and we can
control language and control
the world then that's what matters to me
because that is what engine
what engineered my politics yeah so what
happened is
is these these theorists had some kind
of interesting ideas but their
their ideas were harvested through by
activists
and were turned against themselves when
dara said there is no outside text one
of the problems that
daredevil runs into and this was pointed
out by john searle
in 1983 when he was doing a review of a
book called on deconstruction
and searle he says look
dare does one of the daredest things is
to say that there's no
there is nothing that is central there's
no essence to anything there's no
inherence
there is no he attacks logocentrism the
idea that there's a logos
yeah that's gone meaning the sort of
divine logic of the universe
in the beginning was the word and the
word was with god right that the word
there is the
in the beginning was the logos right
yeah that's right and so daredevil says
all of these things that we've been
talking about plato with the forms
essence um uh god
all of that he says is this logocentrism
which he wants to
deconstruct there's a nice term for it
and do away with it and he says
and dareda comes to the conclusion that
because
there is no central
point all interpretations are endlessly
open for reinterpreting and reprocessing
yeah and searle uh the analytics
philosopher john searle came along and
clocked him and said look when you get
rid of metaphysics dareda
um you're buying into the same things
that you're attacking because
you want to get rid of metaphysics
because you think metaphysics is
necessary for us to have truth
for us to have reality and and what
sorel says and we could nitpick him
about this if we wanted to keep some
metaphysics around but he said the
classical metaphysics
metaphysics of guys like plato of
aristotle
he said that's not necessary for us to
talk about truth
i hereby declare metaphysics is gone
building didn't fall down and
i still see things around you and i can
still talk reality
is the thing that grants us the
objectivity right and while i am a
subject
i am causally connected to the world so
reality is the thing that grants us
objectivity i don't
dareda can attack metaphysics all all he
wants but his
what he thinks that follows from that
and what he was taken as meaning
that there's nothing outside the text
that there's nothing outside of
interpretation that there's nothing
outside of context
that everything is purely contextual and
defined by its context
searle is going to say that's wrong and
i would toss out also
dareda if you think things are only
differ because of context
different virtue of what of the
properties that they have of the thing
that actually makes them up
of the reality yeah daredevil that what
you mean
so cyril points out that dareda's whole
philosophy
is is is is rickety it's on stilts his
his blinding insight isn't actually all
that insightful and what he was taken to
mean
that everything is merely interpretation
yeah that turns out to be entirely wrong
besides which we could ask a very simple
question which is if everything is
entirely interpretable why should we
accept the interpretation that
everything's entirely interpreted right
right right why should i accept your
interpretation
this this reminds me of you know every
freshman philosopher
who you know rips the bong a little too
hard and says you know man
you know there is no truth and you say
okay well with what
authority are you convincing me that
your
statement is objectively true namely
that there is no truth you remind me too
of this line from c.s lewis which i love
where he says the
i'm paraphrasing he writes he writes
better than i talk but he says that the
atheist
can no more blot out god then the
lunatic can blot out the sun
by writing the word darkness on the
walls of his padded cell
and i i love that image that you know
you so dare he does says no
the subjective reality it's it's gone
and you say well
i don't know sun's still shining
everything building still standing looks
real to me
yeah they've so they've taken daredevil
wasn't enough to do it though they
needed somebody else they needed michael
foucault
and as as much as people have tried to
nuance him and say he wasn't really
saying the things that they
that they said he was saying i kind of
think he was
um yeah and what was arguing was that
what is considered to be truth or things
get truth is a status that we bestow on
ideas
socially it's a social status like
saying um
you know president is something that we
bestow on joe biden by virtue of an
election or
prime minister something we bestow on
justin trudeau by virtue of an election
truth is a is a is something that we
bestow on ideas by virtue of our social
institutions
right and so he's this is what he
that idea that truth is a product of
discourses and power
that truth is a social entity that is
created using
power via discourse the way we talk and
discuss
things that idea took hold
and so all of a sudden you have these
people on the one hand who say
everything is just context and we can
reinterpret things endlessly
and then you have another people hold on
and say all of the ideas that we have
are really just a product of discourse
and of power and and now you can do two
things one is you can every time someone
says
you know i think that
i don't know lower taxes are good
they're going to come along and say
that's
that's a power move you're saying that
because
lower taxes will help your side gain
power
yeah yeah and everything is due to the
lens of power but not only is everything
viewed for the lens of power it's also
endlessly reinterpretable yeah right
so when everything is can be endlessly
reinterpreted
and everything is just uh is seen as a
mask for power all of a sudden you can
see what the problem
the problems that that crop up and you
can see this
tying it back to the caitlyn jenner
thing when someone says look i don't
think
the trans women who are biologically
male should be allowed to compete in
women's sports what they'll tell you is
the foucaultian answer is you don't
really care about women's sports you
don't watch the nba this is about
controlling women's bodies so that's the
power thing
and then they'll say now here is the the
reinterpretation of the symbols is to
say look
the idea of what a woman is is um
we can pick what words mean we can
decide what things mean
and we can reinterpret the idea of a
woman to refer to the social role
right you do both of those things at
once and all of a sudden women went from
women's sports goes from people with a
particular biology being able to compete
with each other on a fair playing
field to people who are in a particular
social role
playing against each other regardless of
their biology and you can see this sarah
silverman
uh i did an interesting little thing
about it just recently she said
what about the category she says well
what about tall women yeah
what about some women are bigger than
other women and what she's doing is
she's
is she's calling on the type of
deconstruction that went on in the 70s
where they would say
it's it's all just context right
that's why they say that um who was it
recently that said that testosterone
samantha bee yeah on full frontal is
meant to be said testosterone doesn't
isn't the thing that makes someone a
better athlete and what she's doing is
she's saying look
by itself if i just inject a bunch of
testosterone into me i won't become a
great athlete
therefore testosterone isn't the thing
that does it this is the univariate
fallacy right where you
where you say because i changed that one
because the one thing
by itself isn't enough that means
that it's you can't make any judgments
based upon that so saying that
testosterone by itself isn't the
deciding factor is a little bit like
saying bullets have never killed anybody
they haven't they haven't they're just
sitting there on the table
you know you need some you need some
metal that's formed into a gun you need
a barrel
you have a handle you need aim you need
oxygen you need energy why are you going
around
spreading this fallacy that bullets are
killing people you need organs to be
ripped up i mean you know though i have
to say to give
sarah silverman and michelle foucault
some credit here
when when we're imagining foucault to
say this and when we actually heard
sarah silverman say this verbatim and
she says
this isn't about women's sports you
don't care about women's sports the fact
is
i don't i don't care about women's
sports i've never watched women's sports
i guess in the gymnastics of the
olympics or curling or something i don't
know
occasionally if it happens to be on
otherwise i just don't follow it and i
don't it doesn't interest me regular
sports you know like real sports with
guys that doesn't really interest me
either
okay but what does interest me is
reality what does interest me is the the
conception of truth
as eternal and uh grounded in reality
and the conception of truth is just
something socially constructed and to
your point
you've just made me think of it the
traditional understanding of truth in
our culture in christendom
is that christ is the truth and
he is when he is standing there before
pontius pilate
saying i come to give testimony to the
truth and pilate
who's not the good guy in the story
right you've got the bad guy there
he cynically asks what is truth as
though he were
derrida or or any of these
postmodernists that we see
and and the idea that truth is just this
uh
sort of label that we use for popular
ideas that the society has come to
embrace
well what happens to christ in the in
the passion narrative uh
christ is scorned he's abandoned
he is scourged and he's crucified
doesn't sound very popular to me does it
even by his closest friends
so you've got that conception of truth
which is the one that i
i go to and then now you've got this
post-modern idea that you've described
that
nah man it's just you know whatever we
all think is popular and it's about
power dynamics
so i i totally see your point that we
have
transformed we have gotten here there
were particular thinkers
going back at least to the 60s that have
brought us here but it didn't just start
in the 60s either
i know i know we could be here all day
if i keep asking you to go further and
further back
but it didn't just start in the 60s that
there were writers in the 30s
and 40s and the 1920s and the 1890s and
you know i hate to ask you to trace uh
you know centuries of intellectual
history in about uh
five minutes but how did we even get to
derryda
well daredevil was was picking up on
ferdinand cesar's idea of structuralism
right that's where he comes from where
where fernandez is the first one to say
words get their meaning from other words
and those words get their meaning from
other words and
you just words are just endlessly
defined by other words and the meaning
is found in the structure and daredevil
comes along and says okay what structure
right there's no structure it's just
words endlessly referring to other words
yeah
and so i i think because we could go
back forever i mean even
nietzsche talks about in the death of
god he says who has wiped away the
horizon right and he's talking about the
demarcations of reality
right i think the thing that we need to
do
right now um is we need to get back to
the idea of truth
as corresponding to to reality that it's
not
endlessly interpretable and
deconstructable even with what you did
with sarah silverman there's something
you said well i don't care about women's
sports no but you do care about fairness
you're right well exactly i care about
fairness and justice and truth and
reality yeah and what is she doing when
she does that what she's doing is she's
is she saying you don't care about
women's sports that's meant to be
interpreted as
as your your care about here isn't an
intrinsic concern for the wnba your
concern is about power no my concern is
about fairness
because once you bring fairness into the
wnba what's to stop you from bringing it
into the nba
if people can use particular chemicals
and hormones and whatever and have
whatever testosterone the levels they
want and pay in the wnba
well what's to stop a guy from the nba
saying um
i'm i'm gonna have whatever testosterone
levels i want and he's on steroids
right there's it there's no end point
for it right
so i think we have to get back to the
idea of truth that it corresponds to the
world and corresponds to reality
right we'll get there first right that's
the first thing we've got to do
is bring back the objectivity remember
if your foundation doesn't have any
objectivity to it when you're building
meets the world it's going to collapse
well if you're
if you're if your way of thinking has no
objectivity in its foundation when your
ideas meet the world they'll collapse
too okay
so i think that's the first thing to do
i i totally agree but and the reason i
suppose i've asked about this further
back
intellectual history of where this all
comes from is because the problem seems
so deeply embedded
going back you know just to give a very
sort of broad sketch
you've got the the new left rises in the
60s right guys like herbert marcus the
father of the new left
where does he come from he comes from
the frankfurt school and critical theory
which
we're now seeing a lot of the emanations
of critical theory where does critical
theory come from well it
ultimately goes back to marx what does
mark say he wants to engage on
the ruthless criticism of all that
exists tearing down everything an early
discussion of of deconstruction to use
the popular word
and and frankly i think it goes back
further
than mark's so now we're you're saying
we need to ground
our our sense of the world in reality
again well how do we do that after
centuries of this gradual
poisoning of our of our world view
so if you want to go back we could talk
about hegel if we have to go back there
although
yeah i don't want to talk about nick not
a hegel fan
um so
the the way i like to think about this
because people point it at the
what we call critical social justice
which is the term i use the po
the woke movement if you will yeah they
pointed and say this is updated marxism
and i go
kind of not the correct way to think
about it the kind of way to think about
it is marx kicked marxism off rolling
down a hill
and as snowball went it picked up all
kinds of things
right what we're seeing right now is a
is a mutated
stew of of
of marxist conflict theory theory the
critical theory of the 1930s
uh the new left um that kicked off with
marcus in the 60s
uh daredes and foucault's post-modern
analysis
the way that that post-modern analysis
was laundered through
um um queer theory in the 90s via judith
butler
and through post-colonial theory edward
saeed homie baba get sherry spivak
um all the way up and now that
has that thing got toxified and then
memified right and and it trickled down
through tumblr so
if you think about it like this there's
here's another nice way to think about
it pretend i have a bright light and the
further i get away from the bright light
the dimmer the light gets
yeah okay i i think of if the light is
the truth we're getting away dimmer but
the the truth still shines bright
okay the the the critical theorists
the postmodernism is like
um it's like a rotting chicken
and the more the further it just rots
and
decomposes that's all it does there was
no
no better thing they might well someone
will nitpick my analogy and say well
what about the real chicken you know
give me a break imagine you started with
a rotten chicken and then you just like
let it ferment and keep fermenting and
fermenting it because it's toxic and
toxic and toxic right
it's not like the sweet grapes of truth
that are fermented into the wine
of the of the of the modern world it's
like
the rotting chicken of foucault and
daredevil that are just degrading into
tumbler level activism right
this is what we're doing this is what
we're dealing with here right so
those ideas got all picked up and were
used explicitly for political reasons
and it gets laundered through and dumbed
down as those
so there's a sense in which some of
these people um try to hide and they'll
say well you know
that's not real critical theory yeah no
but the toxicness of critical theory
when you go back and you read marcus's
essays on say repressive tolerance
it's just as bad then right it's just
more academic and it's steel man by
by really powerful intellect so it looks
like it's a lot better
right but it's still rotten right to its
core and right to its bones
so i think what we need to do is that
stuff has been allowed to sit and
ferment in various
various areas of the humanities
um postmodernism and post-modern
philosophy
really didn't get a hold in in
i mean it's not even it's not really
even popular in france where it got
kicked off
it really got a hold in english
literature departments
yeah because when you can reinterpret
anything endlessly
boy that's useful in art right all of a
sudden i can decontextualize one piece
of art
with another piece of art and i can i
can put them beside each other and
juxtapose them and create a new piece of
art
reinterpreting things endlessly in the
artistic world has some utility and some
use it allows us to create new meaning
i want people to do that with art i
don't want them to do that with the cure
for cancer
right i don't i don't want some
postmodern person to like pull up
the the the uh the ingredient list for
hiv drugs and say we're going to
reinterpret this
and then market it i that's bad don't do
that well
that's not exactly in the realm of
science you saw during the the blm riots
and the covet lockdowns there was a
letter
signed by 1200 public health experts
they had very fancy degrees they had
wonderful really
impressive training and they said it's
bad
when conservatives go to church or when
they go protest their civil liberties
being taken away
but it is good when blm goes out and
steals nike sneakers and riots
because white supremacy is a lethal
public health threat
that predates and exacerbates covid19
so you see this language seeping into
the science
but it doesn't sound very scientific to
me they're taking the credibility
from their their work in
say immunology yeah and they're using
that to launder through
the blm activist vision of the world
right yeah and and all of the political
ideas that are contained within the blm
organization such as
the deconstruction of the family the
abolishing of the police and buying
patricia lures five houses
right these are all the things that are
are
are part of that and i mean we can we
have a little fun with it
point is that these these people are in
very
real ways doing deep damage
to to the credibility of science as an
institution
because they're using it to bolster
their credibility in other
in other areas and this is not
appropriate this was never what this was
was was designed to do what i wrote back
then was medical experts
said coven 19 meant we have to close
businesses cancel weddings council
church
funerals and stay at home most of us
through tears and broken hearts listen
then and i
have and do and did advocate for
lockdowns where they were appropriate
and where they were necessary
i think that they were needed in some
places i think that that
that lockdowns particularly in the early
part of the pandemic when we didn't know
what we were dealing with were entirely
justified
but in that early part of the pandemic
when they were doing that and los
angeles downtown los angeles filled up
with
35 000 people saying
you know black lives matter and i
believe that the
life of every black person is is
important i believe that we need to be
fair and treatment equally what a
controversial opinion
i can't say such an unpopular opinion
but when
but when when you have a black lives
matter rally and they say well
this is okay people are looking around
saying well wait a second
you're you're deciding what spreads and
what doesn't yep
based upon what suits your political
ideology yeah
you've politicized your field and now we
no longer trust you
and the
the cynical sort of
attitude of of the postmodern theorists
has been yeah but it was always already
political
yeah that's what they think they think
everything was political so my
my thing is i have been very vocally
pro-locked down very very pro very
vocally pro-vaccine
and when when that letter came out i
just looked at this and i said
you people have sold your inheritance of
credibility and trust
for the mess of pottage of a single
rally in l.a right and i cannot believe
that you did it you
sold your credibility for nothing
well on the point of the continued to do
it on the point of the lockdowns and the
vaccine it
it's funny now to look at it because
i think that the state absolutely has a
right to certain emergency police powers
during a pandemic or something like that
i think that vaccines have a long
history and
there are various ways that the state
has coerced vaccines and
that has perfect standing in american
politics but the issue is
that these people who are signing these
letters and the dr pouches of the world
who go on tv and lie to you
and say the masks don't work and then
five seconds later they say
you need to wear the masks i only lied
so that my nurses got more masks
when and i'm only slightly paraphrasing
him there when they squander that
credibility then then
i say that every time they open their
mouths i become 15
less likely to abide by their lockdown
orders or to get the vaccine or use the
passport or whatever
yeah um the professor of s of uh of
epidemiology
s seth prince s underscore j underscore
prince
p-r-i-n-s said that public health
officials needed to
quote pick a side can
can you imagine telling people that
we've picked a side
yeah all of a sudden people who are like
well
i'm on the other side and i need health
care why would i trust you right why on
earth
you know why would any police officer
ever take advice from a public health
official again
these people have used their platforms
to pick a side and say it should be
the goal of public health to abolish the
police that's from uh
epi ellie she she quoted a graphic that
she had originally made for protesters
and for police and she changed it and
said
um as one of the original creators of
this research of this revised graphic
disarm defund and abolish that's what
she said
all of a sudden if like if you're a
police officer and the professor of
immunology says
i i no longer believe that police should
be allowed out and i want to defund
disarmament abolish them
if you're a police officer or a police
chief in a major area and you need
information for how to keep your police
officers safe
are you going to go to to that professor
of immunology
is that what you're going to do no so
these people have
by deciding to use their their the
platform that they got
for health care to launder through their
political ideas
yeah is is breaking the credibility of
everybody and the point here
is i think it can't be overstated
the politicization of everything because
they think
everything is already political if
that's what you buy into
if you think that everything is always
already political
then you have no problem dragging
politics in but when you think
everything is always already political
then anytime someone who disagrees with
you says something
you're now analyzing what they said
through the lens of okay what is their
political goal here
but i want i'd like to understand who
does that
sure no i i i see that point and i i
think i agree broadly but to
to stand up for these insane leftists
for a second
or you know i i guess it was expressed
most concisely by the second wave
feminists when they say that
the personal is the political right this
is where this idea kind of breaks down
into the mainstream
when they say that they make a real
point which is that
my personal life the way that i interact
with my husband
as a housewife of the 1970s the way i
interact with my society
the way that i interact with schooling
or go to work that has
a political basis to it that it rests on
certain political premises rests on a
very pol
you know political arrangement of
society it rests on
a religious foundation too and i
as a feminist i'm going to question all
of that and i'm going to say a woman
needs a man like a fish needs a bicycle
and i'm going to say as simone de
beauvoir said you know jean-paul
sartre's trumpet and a very famous
feminist herself
she said it is women should not be
allowed to stay at home with the
children
it this is a political matter if we let
women stay at home the politics will
never change
so we've got to change their personal
decisions coerce their personal
decisions
and then we'll have a better polity than
we
we currently have i think just
in the most modest way aren't they
making an important point
that our private decisions exist
in a political context because we're all
living in society together
so i think how do i say this
there are two ways in which to handle
that sentence first off
um people say you know a woman needs a
man
like a fish needs a bicycle um
imagine if we went to like i don't know
found an endangered species
like the panda and someone said we need
more pandas and i said
the female pandas need a male panda the
way the fish needs a bicycle
right this is how the human species
repopulates and keeps going
so i think it's absurd if you take it at
its
best it could say well socially or
my value or whatever else but it really
just turns out to
um the idea a sort of an atomistic view
of life where i am complete
unto myself disconnected from anything
and so what they have the critical
social justice has taken a high-low
coalition where
uh at the level of the individual my
choices should be absolutely
unencumbered but
at the level of society society has to
be adjusted entirely
so that to accommodate me to accommodate
all of
to accommodate well to they would say to
be fair to accommodate
everybody living how they the life which
they have constructed for themselves
according to their
way of knowing right yeah they would say
this as liberatory
yeah right they think that they are
liberating themselves from the clutches
of enlightenment liberalism
and its demands for objective truth
which is really just a prison right
foucault was once quoted as saying
someone said do you want to go to heaven
and he said i don't know am i allowed to
leave
right because i can't leave it's just a
prison right right that's that's
the the self a gentle automation
unchecked by anything
is what matters right so they would say
that for everyone so they would say they
want to liberate us
from having person from having
responsibilities this is why they hate
jordan peterson so much because they're
saying we want to liberate ourselves
from any
from having the responsibilities of
everyone else and people incumbent
on themselves and jordan peterson comes
along and says take on as much
responsibility as you can
right right it's opposite ideology you
mention here enlightenment liberalism as
sort of the
that objective standard that they're
rebelling against
but could one not also point to
enlightenment liberalism and say
ah therein lies the problem because out
of enlightenment liberalism we get a
whole lot of
treatises about tolerance we get a whole
lot of tracts about pluralism
we get a sort of cracking up perhaps of
the
uh certainty of the truth i mean this is
this is what hamlet is about right
hamlet is
basically about martin luther as far as
i can tell is about the crack up of this
this monopoly on truth in the west and
uh so
could could one i'm not saying that i'm
saying this but i suppose i am saying
this
that one could look look back at this
moment and say rather than the
vindication of objective truth
there began this descent into you do you
i would say two things about that as
someone who has defended enlightened
enlightenment liberalism fairly robustly
i say we have a version of
enlightened liberalism which i'm seeking
is
one which suffices as a
[Music]
conflict resolution strategy the
enlightenment liberal
is going to say that when there's a
conflict in society we have particular
methods
of doing so democracy
the rule of law applying equally
fundamental human rights
and truth right
enlightenment liberalism cannot provide
your life with
the meaning that undergirds it it was
never meant to do that that's not its
goal
enlightenment liberalism says that
there's muslims and jews and christians
and atheists and feminists and these
people all need to be able to somehow
get along and work with each other and
the post-modernist comes along and says
aha why should we follow enlightenment
liberalism we can deconstruct all of
that
and then once they've deconstructed
everything all of those conflict
resolution strategies are now gone
i think this is this is a very good
point but but it it
does require one answer here which is
john locke father of liberalism john
locke writes
the great letter concerning toleration
and he says we got to tolerate everybody
you know because that's how we're all
going to
that's how we're going to resolve
conflicts and get along in society and
we're going to tolerate everybody
except for atheists atheists have no
claim on toleration
they actually they cannot be tolerated
or the society is going to fall apart
now today of course nobody nobody quotes
that part of john locke
but what it seems what he's getting at
here is we need to have some
common ground we need to be standing on
some common ground here
because if if we with regard to morality
ethics
the the way we view ourselves in the
universe because if we don't
you can't you couldn't even have that
conflict resolution
right and and this is kind of part of
the problem where we're at with
post-modernism is that the
post-modernists are standing on an
entirely different thing
i think part of the problem is that that
post-modernism only ever spits itself
back in redefined and bastardized
versions of the concepts that we use
which is why when they say racism sexism
and homophobia we're against those
things and we say
i'm against those things too they have
an entirely different set of definitions
from what that
those things mean right so when you say
i'm against you know i would say i'm
against transphobia i don't think that
caitlyn jenner should be beaten up on
the way to buy eggs and cheese and and
get groceries and do other things that
caitlyn jenner wants to i think that's
not a problem by the way good luck
beating up caitlyn jenner caitlyn jenner
is the the greatest athlete that's ever
lived you know i mean that good luck
you're not going to beat that guy up you
know
but they would say that transphobia
extends even to your
thoughts yeah um there was a paper that
was written by i believe it was robin i
want to say robin dembele from yale who
argued that
if to avoid using a trans person's
chosen pronouns you use their name
so if i say caitlyn jenner instead of
she that that's still a subtle form of
transphobia because i haven't
i haven't used the opportunity because
i've used the opportunity where i would
have normally used a pronoun to sub it
out and in doing so i have denied
caitlyn jenner's
i have failed to affirm caitlyn jenner's
female identity right
the enlightenment liberal would tell you
to toss off with that and get out of
here
but the post-modernist would say no and
so you're right
the post-modernist the core assumptions
of the postmodernist
are in inherently social radical social
constructivism of absolutely everything
right um and so that is really the
core of the problem that we're seeing
because that's the thing that filters
down and uploads so easily
into a world of photoshop right that
everything is just socially constructed
just
uploads just so wonderfully and simply
on on onto the internet
um that kind of of nitpicky
kind of 2016 era tumbler activism
uploads really easy when you just want
to reinterpret everything and say well
this really means this and this really
means this
that kind of stuff uploads so simply
into that world right yeah and that's
where it
it kind of can take off in a way that
slow
careful rigor doesn't really take off
yeah right like i can take a meme of
so somebody said um oh i can't remember
who it was but
if you know what a diminutive is like
when i say my cat like who's a good boy
that's a diminutive yeah yeah
that's my that's my italian dominion
megalooch it's a little like
a cute little little mega little yeah so
the postmodernist person comes along and
says
um i deconstruct gender binder all
all the time but i always talk to my kid
good boy because gender is just a
diminutive linguistic construct
that's that's it to them and they've
reinterpreted the whole thing and you go
look at that and you say
i see how you did that it's complete
nonsense but i see how that works yeah
i see what you're doing there it's just
endless endless reinterpretation of the
signs and symbols because that's the
entire world
the discourse in which they live in
right
so everything is just discourse so
when the enlightenment liberal says i
believe that there are facts about the
world
that are that are indubitable that are
true that are
correct that there's something that we
can contact with
immediately you're all already stepping
away because what the postmodernist is
going to say is going to say no no no no
you're filled with so much bias and
you're filled with so much
a a longing for power and and nothing
that you say can be taken at face value
and you're badly motivated so we have to
deconstruct your motives and
and you've been socialized in and so by
the time they're done
there's no stable correct true or
absolute sentences because every
sentence that you say could have been
reinterpreted anyway right the world is
constructed in systems of
power right right science is just a
system of
power now you might want to
tip a hat to foucault a little bit and
say
some of the people who are urging
[Music]
for some of the
coveted legislation to stick around
permanently
uh-huh a foucault might have a look at
that and say see i told you so
yeah right the problem is that foucault
thinks that's the whole world
right yeah these guys i mean there is a
way in which dare to has a point about
some stuff and what you could say yeah
things can be reinterpreted we can
we can um
take something old and use it for
something new i can
juxtapose these two different paintings
to create a new piece of art that's okay
and there's something about foucault
where you could say yeah you know what
there are certain times when
when someone's credibility in one
particular
area of the academic world
becomes to use a term from the economic
world fungible
and then extend them to other areas
where they use their
their say credibility and i don't know
mathematics to opine on all kinds of
different things which is why we might
ask michael jordan
or lebron james or um you know tom
cruise about moral issues right because
it extends
their credibility their and their social
credibility extends out and we might say
foucault has a point about some of this
stuff
the problem is not that sure sometimes
power gets abused by people
and sure sometimes people take the stuff
out and go in wrong directions with it
and sure sometimes institutions who have
credibility
and we trust to do the rigorous work of
providing this truth
use that trust to launder through
political ideology that can happen
but to say that that's the whole show
yeah yeah and that
everything always everywhere is just
wrong
and so what i would want to do is i
would want to say is that the ideology
that's been constructed out of their
ideas
needs to be i mean i would say that you
and i are acting somewhat
deconstructively on a meta-narrative
here
go on deconstruct that unpack that
please
yeah we might be acting in a
deconstructive way on some other
meta-narratives
and we might be wanting to point out to
them um
that that part of their tactics rely
entirely on creating
social asymmetries where they're allowed
to deconstruct you but you can't
deconstruct them back
right and that's the point about
intersectionality by the way
that's the thing that crenshaw thinks
that she can put her linchpin on the
un the universal solvent
of post-modernism sits in the jar of of
personal experience which can't be
deconstructed right
right you can't deconstruct my
experience
of living as a woman as a black woman
and she couldn't understan uh
deconstruct my experience as living as a
jewish white male who's converted to
christianity in canada
and or deconstruct your your experience
of of of swearing
in podcasting in tennessee
you know she would say you can't
deconstruct those things right
and and then they have the standpoint
epistemology which says that the person
at the
at the that everyone can see the
dominant view because it's dominant
and the this on this bottom view under
here
yeah right that that's the view that
nobody sees or understands
and one might want to ask them uh given
that you share the same views as
coca-cola who's the dominant view in
society at the moment
coca-cola and the administrative state
and big tech so
now we've obviously run way over time in
the interview but i don't care
my producers want to go to lunch too bad
i in our remaining minutes here i need
to ask this
i can't i i'm too depressed by
everything you've told me
i need to know the answer people have
proposed
many different answers to this problem
of the wokeness and the
kind of postmodern gel of the jelly that
we're all living in where
nothing makes any sense and we can't
really seem to move some people have
said we ought to we ought to go back to
enlightenment liberalism just restore
the ve
go back in time to the values of
enlightenment liberalism that'll be
great some people have said we need to
go back a little further still
maybe those catholics had a point maybe
we need to
be a little firmer in our declaration of
truth some people have said
that we need to you know i think of the
identitarian types that we need to
basically be if the left is going to be
racist we need to be racist you know we
need to have a
hyper focus on race if they're going to
be atheists you know we're going to be
atheists too but we're
we're going to choose to perform certain
religious rituals just because you know
they're good or something or they're
but it doesn't matter if they're true
but they're you know anyway they they're
conducive to society
and people have all these different
ideas
what's your idea i want to see nothing
less than the return of the logos to
prominence and western civilization
sounds high yeah uh and i
i could think of a quite a few
philosophers who might want to have that
with me
um and they might construe it
differently they might construe some
would construe the logos as christ other
people are going to construe the logos
as
as truth other people are going to
construe the logos as wisdom and
understanding reality but the
the logos needs to come back um
cyril when he uh in his
in his view says that we could take
daredevil's deconstruction and we can
just deconstruct it right back and show
him to be a classical metaphysician
right the acid of post-modernism eats
everything including itself it doesn't
leave anything
left right so i wanna i wanna
before you go on i i wanna make sure
nobody missed that point
that you can use derrida to undermine
derrida you can use
the sort of post-modernism to undermine
the post-modernism and turn it into
whatever you want well we can turn
dairy duh into a pope gregory the great
if we want to right it's just words
words words
well i wouldn't he dare to be to be fair
with data he would say it's endlessly
open to interpretation it's always
endlessly open he wouldn't say you can
interpret it just any way you want but i
would turn that around and say
well darren i guess what you're saying
is open
and since you buy the death of the
author and that the author doesn't get
to decide what the work means after it
leaves his pen
yep i guess you don't get to decide what
your work means after it leaves yours
the the way i mean this goes back to the
foundation would you do that with the
foundation right all the postmodern
stuff is is operating
as as our friend i wish he was my friend
the cl our colloquial friend john cyril
points out is that
all of their therefores and um
as a result and in light of and all the
inferences that they claim from their
claims are based on the very rationality
that they're trying to get rid of
yeah right they're using rationality to
try and get rid of rationality the point
is that if you ever succeeded in doing
that you'd have undermined rationality
which means that your whole critique
would have been undermined from the
get-go
right so what i would say is
to put it to put it simply when someone
says to you there is no truth
the response of is that true
should tie them up in knots right and
typically the way that they've done
is to kind of live with a sort of
detached irony right
because nothing matters yeah yeah so the
way that we go out of this is that we
can't go
back we have to go through
that's the only way out of this is
through we can't
undo it there's no there's no unweaving
the rainbow
so to steal a phrase from richard
dawkins right we can't
we can't undo it there's no way back
there's no stepping out
we have to go through it so i think the
first thing that we want to do or
something that we need to make sure that
we're doing when we're attacking this
stuff is to get clear about the
constellation of concepts
that populate the motivational economy
of the people that are pushing this
stuff
we want to get really clear about how
all of these things relate to each other
so that we can see the endless
circularity that they use
right to try and make their stuff go we
want to understand their power moves and
social pressure tactics
right that they use and why they when we
get into an argument about truth they
instantly switch to moral shaming
because they're not interested in having
debate about what the facts are
yeah they're interested in gaining
social power we need to understand that
we need to move through and then i think
we return
we don't return we bring through with us
before you go on i just have to clarify
here when you say
you know they're they're using these ad
hominems and they're just moral shaming
and whatever
they're attacking you and you say we
have to
not try to avoid that but go through
what do you mean go through it
like just take it or oh oh no i mean
that having the wherewithal for example
white fragility when someone says you
have white
you say i'm not a racist they say you
have white fragility yeah you have to
immediately expose that as a kafka trap
okay you have to immediately suppose
oppose that and say look
what you're saying is that if i say i'm
not white
racist i have white fragility and that
white fragility is proof that i have
racist and you know that i'm a racist
because i have white fragility which
proves that i'm a racist like
you you immediately have to call the
bluff on it right
the the their whole game is to attack
the assumptions that you make yeah the
the response is to say all the stuff
that
all the games that you're playing is
relying on my assumptions too
a nice way to do this i mean if you're
going back to the caitlyn jenner thing
when they say
um this this person is wearing a dress
this person is wearing makeup this
person
has got a wig on this person identifies
as female
why is that not enough and you say can
men wear dresses
well yeah okay can men wear makeup yeah
okay so then what does that have to do
with anything with being a woman
right you have to you have to
demonstrate the absurdity of it right
you have to show that their
their own assumptions are are
that they re that the whole to be trans
to go from male to female relies on the
existence of a gender binary yeah
you couldn't go from male to female
unless there was a male and a female to
go from
and to go to of course yeah right so i
have no pr if someone has gender
dysphoria and says this is the only way
that i can live
we can have a discussion about that and
i would probably be okay with that if
someone says but you have to actually
believe
now that i am this thing that i claim to
be i can say
no there's a biological reality here
that undergirds this right
so when someone moves with you on an ad
hominem to immediately expose
the tactic for what it is is of absolute
paramount
porn expose the kafka trap expose the
circular reasoning
expose the argument via insinuation
expose the unjustified inferences at all
times
everywhere always when they say you're
misinterpreting me and they want to say
well you have to read this 4
000 page book you immediately say if
you're demanding charitability from me
reading you then you must give me the
same charitability in the way you read
me and if you don't
yeah then i'm i'm justified all these
social
and argumentative asymmetries need to be
called out immediately
you go through them you can't go around
them you can't avoid them you have to
rip them apart
great points this is a very dantein
point i like the only way out is through
that dante
you know to give us the vision of heaven
he doesn't get to just jump right up and
go to heaven
he has to go down through the very
bowels of hell and crawl across
satan up to purgatory and up to heaven
yeah so then the second thing that you
do is you have to take
the things about what social justice is
pointing at which
give it its plausibility um
you have to be able to show how those
don't justify the philosophy and the
social ontology
their social philosophy that they've
created out of this their
their critical social justice doesn't
hold together yeah you have to drive
that apart
i then i think that you have to there is
a
very strong tradition i think most
people hold to it they're kind
of ducking and covering right now
because all of the cultural megaphones
are owned by woke people
yeah um and we need people i mean john
mcquarter went uh i think yesterday of
the day before on bill maher's show and
just lit wokeness on fire and it was
absolutely beautiful we need more of
that
um so i think going through it means
that we have to come through on the
other side with a version of
enlightenment liberal which said
enlightenment liberalism which says this
is a conflict resolution strategy
built around democracy human rights
property rights freedom um the power
utility and strength of science
um the usefulness of markets and then
say um um
we're going to keep that through but
we're going to
adopt an understanding of that which
which
allows us to push to to filter out the
postmodern view of the world
that inoculates us from that right
that's what we want to do
if if i mean the the
the cr the the wuhan lab of wokeness of
at least the virus
we need the vaccine now right so what
we're going to do is inoculate ourselves
from it by understanding
how these kafka trap works we're gonna
we're gonna bring back the logos we're
gonna bring back reason and objectivity
we're gonna bring back an understanding
of the
well though i myself may not be able to
be fully objective
we can create universities and systems
of peer review which
rather than functioning as ideal
laundering factories for woke activism
can actually
suffice to be places where people can
criticize
and within that criticism we can hammer
out
and we can we can polish off all of this
subjectivity and get
and get to truth and then i think the
enlightened liberals need to
understand that human beings crave
meaning
and that the enlightenment liberal
framework
the enlightenment liberal framework is
to create conflict resolution
within society within science within
truth
and within politics but it does not
create meaning
so how do we create meaning that's all
i'm interested in that's why this is why
i
kind of am being somewhat derisive of
the enlightenment liberal thing i want
the meaning darn it
give me a system with meaning i mean if
we just want to talk about meaning
that's a fight that's a quick
five-minute thing
the meaning the meaning of of life is is
found in the drinking of woke tears oh
no
[Laughter]
no i actually think that a lot of people
who've been swept up in wokeness
um have been swept up because they've
been drinking it out of the culture i'll
make an even more controversial claim
and you can edit this out if you have to
let bring it on please i want it donald
trump is the first post-modern president
yeah i agree i agree well my the only
way i'll disagree or push back even
slightly is
obama may have anticipated that obama
obama may
i i see your point on on trump and i'd
like you to go
go into it a little bit more but i think
many of the
eccentricities of trump i think you see
pre-figured a little bit
in in obama but i i'd like to hear more
about your point on trump
i think that obama would have been oh
there was a wonderful essay written by
james lindsay talking about this exact
thing about different
eras so you have the initial era then
you have the reconstruction era
uh then you have for example uh okay the
liberal era
in the uh or so fdr that era then you
have the neoconservative euro starting
with
say ronald reagan and moving all the way
up and now
obama could have been a new liberal era
but
that movement obama i think was a
liberal
okay but obama started getting attacked
and criticized
as being not far far enough by the
up-and-coming millennial class
of journalists creators and all the rest
of it
and that
um the post-modernism was coming i think
obama may have seen it and was trying to
operate within it and figure out what to
do with it yeah
right after especially after getting
slacked in 2010 yeah yeah um
i think he tried to figure out i think i
think trump just intuited it mm-hmm
where trump says uh i could be
presidential i could be presidential
right do you remember this video
but that would be boring there's another
video where he's talking on camera and
then he kind of stops from when he says
and then goes right back to it i think
trump
intuited and understood i don't think
trump's ever read judith butler
i don't think he's read gender trouble
um i don't think that he's ever read
um orientalism by edward said or or the
grammatical or of gramatology by jacques
darda i think that lucky guy
i think yeah i think he sat for 11 years
doing the apprentice and saw how the
media ecosystem work
yeah yeah and then i'll make another
claim
so we're going to do this real brief if
we're talking about
q q anon is post modernism on the right
yeah
yeah q anon is post modernism and it's
also you could describe it as an oral
tradition right
because it always gets banned everywhere
so it's just in the retelling of the
story that it recreates itself
and the whole story of it only exists in
the ruins of dead forms
that are ossifying and decaying away in
in internet archives in various places
right
but 1980
ed rollins puts everything on the table
and fights hard to get ronald reagan
elected
yeah yeah yeah then
who who who did ed rollins bring on he
brought in who lee atwater
and lee atwater um is the one who ran
the willie horton ad
to get george h.w bush right
so you have we're getting reagan elected
and from reagan we degrade a little bit
to bush
right but we're still maybe the most
qualified man to ever be president is
george w bush he's got a great resume
that guy
yeah and and a good man but the
operative around them is the atwater
now you fast forward to to
um the bush era and it's karl rove
and who was the atwater's chief disciple
it's rick wilson really everybody
actually didn't know that
rick wilson was taught by lee atwater
rick wilson ran the ad against
max cleland in 2000
through 2002 to get saxby chambliss
elected
so ed roland sold his soul to get ronald
reagan elected
rick wilson sold his soul for saxby
shameless
right but hold on go a little further
that ad
has rick wilson actually defended this i
will afterwards if you want i can send
you the screenshots of this
because rick left him on the timeline
and i can dig
and he defends that ad says i didn't say
anything false no what you did is you
had a picture of max cleland juxtaposed
or turning into
osama bin laden i can't remember whether
they juxtaposed or turned into
and said that he didn't have the courage
to lead
max cleanland is a triple amputee from
vietnam
who opposed what george h.w bush was
what george w
bush was doing in 2002 with the iraq war
on the basis
of the costs to the future and not
wanting to give them a blank check
and rick wilson basically came out and
said you are osama bin laden
okay you want to know why trump gets off
attacking a gold star mom rick
you set the paradigm right wow what an
amazing tidbit i
actually had had no idea about rick
wilson's role in that
i'll do you i'll do you even one better
than that
you step forward people are saying well
the populism of the gop of the racism
racist populism of the racist populist
race
it goes back to sarah palin who picked
sarah palin
bill crystal steve schmidt
was the one with in the campaign who was
in the campaign john weaver
you know it wasn't it wasn't just it was
bill
bill crystal and i think charlie sykes
too but certainly bill
discovered her was advocating for her
and then yeah you get steve schmidt and
guys like weaver and
and somehow you get uh uh sarah palin's
entire
lincoln project has on its hands the
fingerprints of
all the bad parts of the trump
presidency
right all of those guys are absolutely
responsible
for all of this if we look at the men
who the people picked
reagan yeah yeah how many men was george
h.w bush married to one how many men was
women sorry was george h.w bush married
two one how many women was george bush
married two
one how you know those are the men that
we're bringing in
right mitt romney the straightest
shooter you could possibly imagine was
picked by the people
who are the consultants it's the lee
atwaters
the rick wilson's the the steve schmitz
the john weavers the rot in the gop
can be entirely traced back to the
people who for years
for absolutely for years in the name of
of a certain kind of of economic program
and in a certain form of foreign policy
ran ads at blatantly attacking people
like
max cleveland to the point where even
john mccain
said that he he refused to campaign with
saxophone shameless because of that ad
yeah yeah and now when donald trump
attacks a gold star mom which was bad it
was terrible
these guys are i am incandescent with
rage
i'm sorry max cleveland would like to
have a word sir yeah
you know i have been salting the ground
for this
yeah for years i should point out
for the fact checkers i should point out
that you know
reagan was remarried but in his defense
his wife left him he did not want to get
remarried he was actually very
very against it but yes certainly he he
lived a very upright life
bush you know of course bush that's one
of the great love stories
ever in politics bush senior um and yeah
you see you do see a sort of
decay and then i ironically these
hypocrite gop consultants who
created the modern gop now they turn on
it as though
their hands are totally clean it's
totally ridiculous it's and it's all the
bad stuff too
yeah like you trace everything bad that
trump did
um is there is there any attack had that
trump ever ran that's anywhere close to
what rick wilson did to max cleland
and he defended it by saying what in the
ad that i say was false
um that max cleland lacks courage i mean
this is a triple amputee
and they cropped the photo so you could
only see his head and shoulders so that
part gets left out gosh
oh we're juxtaposing different things
where do we see
the ripping out of context and the
juxtaposition
that sounds like hmm sounds like
postmodernism
sounds like there is a kind of
postmodern conservativism
in fact we could say that we're living
in i don't know hugely tremendous times
you might say
because right and
these guys are all upset about it but
like let's look at charlie the history
of charlie sykes who did charlie sykes
bring on board who did bill crystal
bring on board
all of these guys mainlined the very
people and we're left now with a group
of people in the in the gop
i'm thinking of kinzinger and cheney and
some of these other people who
who who have mistaken bush era
platitudes and talking points at um
for eternal truths yeah that's right
that's right they thought they thought
that the ossified talking points of the
bush administration were the bones of
eternal truth and they're not
yeah right this is not correct so this
is this is absurd
and so to me i look at the lincoln
project and i think if you want to know
grift yeah don't come at me
don't commit you or ben yeah let's have
a conversation about rick wilson
steve schmidt john john weaver right um
stewart stevens all of these guys who
were
wanted to go blood and guts
you know attacking war veterans
bashing people's patriotism if you're
not with us you're with the terrorists
all of that stuff for years then trump
comes along and says you are fake news
and they're just like well this is the
enemy of the people we need to start the
lincoln project
you can donate here yeah yeah right and
they'll run ads on
on morning joe in washington dc they'll
run their ads in places
that that would never have any effect on
the election but that will milk democrat
donors out of a lot of dollars
right i mean it's the utter insincerity
of this and so
there is a a point and i mean there's
some good and there's some bad the good
people who are still within i would say
a bush
ish kind of conservative paradigm i mean
people i might respect
i think i still i would still respect
david french i think david french is
honest
but unlike know some of those other guys
david french
went to war and yeah he's a veteran yeah
you know
i really like david personally he and i
have always had a great personal
relationship
some of the things he's written recently
i find it difficult to take a charitable
read
on but uh but yeah you know a nice guy
i i you know but you you can you can
read david french and say i disagree
but i don't think that david french is
running an entirely cynical operation
but i think that some of the other guys
are being entirely cynical i mean
yeah yeah that's fair you know i i was i
was getting
made fun of by jon stewart when i wrote
liberal fascism years ago
what have you done and it's like i'm
sorry
that was the interview where i first
realized mr goldberg mr jonah goldberg
i'll say your name because you deserve
it
um that was the first interview where i
realized that there are conservative
charlatans
because jon stewart exposed you for what
you were back in what 2009 it's a joke
it's absurd and so when they say that
the conservative movement has been
intellectually hauled out we might want
to ask who did that
who's in charge for the last 30 years
well you know i love this point too i
guess this
sort of ties it in together uh which i'm
sure my producers will be happy about so
they can go to lunch
that there is these these sorry
i know these no but i uh you know what
what you're saying is
so important for understanding you know
the broader culture and we can knock the
left and how the left brought us here
but also understanding
what that means for our side how our
side has indulged this how we represent
this now
and and for those who say the awful
trump era people
they have they have betrayed true
conservatism capital t capital c
trademark over the e
of you know 2006 or whatever uh you
think well
how did we get here it didn't this
didn't just spring out of the
the air one day you know alone in a
forest this
is a consequence of other ideas and
other actions and and
uh a certain ideology you know that
perhaps has reached the end of the line
and i think there's a group of
conservative people and you touched on
this a little bit who've said hey if the
left is doing this and it's working we
should indulge it too yeah
and this is going to be part of the book
i'm writing which i am writing on
on the tactics which i explain how this
works and
that's not going to work because if you
step onto the postmodern ground with the
people who are postmodern they're native
to it
right this is like having a this is like
having a uh
uh a battle of play on words with a
speaker of a native language and you
just learned it yesterday
right like if i learned spanish tomorrow
and i tried to get into a poetry contest
with a with this native speaking
spaniard that's going to not go real
well
unless we're doing free verse but um you
know like this isn't going to go well
for me
maybe if we're doing a haiku and i only
need eight words or something but i'm
gonna lose
if if i learn how to play hockey
yesterday and i'm going to step on the
ice against connor mcdavid
this is not going to go well for me so
for us to adopt those tactics
bad the thing that we ought to be doing
is adopting the tactics of the
enlightenment liberal and what i say the
tactics of the enlightened sorry the
principles
of the enlightened liberals yeah i
prefer the tactics of the spanish
inquisition but i
agree some of the principles
we need we need to bring the
enlightenment principles in and then we
need to have tactics that pull them onto
that ground because once you pull them
onto the ground of objectivity yeah
their houses crumble
yeah that's true and i suppose then we
can we can pull them back even further
to the glories of europe christian unity
the high church but we'll have to save
that topic
for another time local distance everyone
go follow
vocal i'm sure they've already followed
you after your very illuminating
thoughts but uh you can follow me
w-o-k-a-l underscore distance at
local distance and uh stay tuned for
that that book with words and i having
written a book with words in a book
without words it is a much
tougher undertaking to do one with words
so i commend you for that
where else can people find you uh so
right now it's just the twitter
uh vocal underscore distance that's
that's my twitter handle that's where
you'll find me
i occasionally do interviews on benjamin
voices podcast
on youtube so if you search for
benjaminvoice on on youtube he's got a
lot of wonderful interviews he
interviewed some really great people um
yeah that's where you can find me i
i appreciate you having having me on
absolutely we're gonna have you back
it was fabulous i'm so glad you came on
you're you're
extremely intelligent and uh and that's
a
you know i try not to ever compliment
canadians it just goes against my nature
to say nice things about america's hat
but but uh i i will in your case well as
a canadian
being polite it's it would be untoward
of me to accept it
fair point local thank you so much for
coming on thank you
i appreciate it